so now let's get further into what's
going on with eg and Carol I told you
yesterday that once again Donald Trump
has been accused of rape I don't know
how many total rape and sexual assault
allegations this makes I read one piece
that says eg in Carroll is number 16
another that says she's number 13 others
say 17 I don't know what the answer is
but the latest accuser is a Jean Carol
who says that Donald Trump raped her in
a New York City department store in the
late 1990s she goes into specific and
very explicit detail about it
somehow this garnered very little
corporate media coverage nothing I was
able to find on the Sunday morning talk
shows two days ago only a little bit of
coverage yesterday Joe Biden standing
too close to a woman apparently deserved
a ton of coverage but yet another
accuser who says the President of the
United States raped me gets relatively
little coverage and unfortunately and
this leads to what I was talking about
earlier that accuser a Jean Carol has
now started to receive death threats as
was described to a CNN reporter
yesterday when Joe Biden stands too
close to a woman Joe Biden is the
problem according to the right-wing
Trumpets when a woman accuses Donald
Trump of rape the woman who says she was
raped is the problem to those exact same
trumpets and this is why there's a
fundamental problem in fighting people
for whom this is just sport I talked
about this last week we can't stoop to
their level because it's an immoral
level but at a certain point we also
need to win and take them out of power
so look at the double standard with the
Al Franken and the Roy Moore situations
by the way Roy waters running again and
we'll talk about that soon maybe later
on this week when Al Franken was
involved in an arguably tasteless joke
involving a female reporter and a flak
jacket Republicans demanded that Al
Franken resign and Franken did resign
after even some Democrats said he should
probably go and he resigned his seat
from the US Senate in retrospect there
are many people now on
left who say you know given all the
stuff that Republicans have excused it's
not totally clear that Al Franken should
have resigned but he did resign
meanwhile you had Republican candidate
for US Senate from Alabama Roy Moore who
was accused of multiple instances of
sexual assault including against teenage
girls and he received forty eight point
three percent of the vote from Alabama
voters he lost by under twenty two
thousand votes Democrats have plenty of
scumbags but the rules are not even
remotely the same for how Republicans
and Democrats handle this stuff who was
defending Anthony Weiner a Democrat who
has caught multiple times sexting with
various women now I don't even remember
what I believe one of them was underage
who was defending John Edwards a
Democrat for his mistress Fiasco the
details of which I don't even remember
now I'm sure you can find someone in a
country of 340 million people certainly
there were some people defending Anthony
Weiner and John Edwards but it was few
and far between Newt Gingrich's affairs
while his wife had cancer Donald Trump's
affairs and 15 16 17 sexual assault
allegations Roy Moore serial accused sex
assault er gets 48% of the vote how do
we defeat people who have no rules and
see this only as the sport of wins and
losses and not as real people and real
life I don't know the answer okay but at
a certain point we've got to start
winning and this is you know I'm not
playing coy and saying oh damn Democrats
are victims of their own morality and
Upstate there's plenty of scumbags who
are in power there's plenty of scumbags
who defend those in power who do bad
things on the left but they're playing
by different rules at this point in time
so I don't know what the answer is but
it's abundantly clear that Trump
supporters are not going to be
influenced by allegation after
allegation after allegation and one way
or another this is a guy who has to be
removed but remember that this is a
symptom okay the fact that evangelicals
voted for him even though he goes
against everything they claim to stand
for the fact that they are totally
unwilling to just
say hey this has to stop this is not a
good guy it it is not something that is
going to go away if and when Donald
Trump is removed from office or leaves
office in a year and a half or five and
a half years and this is a bigger sort
of corseting of the dialogue corseting
of morality that we are going to at some
point need to deal with and I genuinely
don't know what the answer is if you
have ideas let us know we'll have a
question about this a poll question on
the David Pakman show
Instagram page later on today or maybe
later this week that's at David Pakman
show on Instagram and while you're there
follow me I'm at David Pakman on
Instagram quick break back after this to
talk about which centrist Democrats
should be the top priorities to primary
with more progressive challengers that's
coming up next if you love learning new
things you probably want to check this
out the David Pakman show today is
sponsored by Skillshare and we're giving
you two entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video